Harry Styles puppy pack new music video
plus Taylor Swift reveals the tracklist
to reputation and the trio of goddesses
hosting this year's Met Gala hello from
the city that never sleeps
which is probably why I'm so damn tired
but we have a new music video from Harry
Styles and I promise you it will fill
your week with so much damn cuteness the
singer has some good old fashioned kid
fun in a floral suit of course now a
group of fighting kids is the backdrop
for the high-energy song when the little
girl dressed in the same suit as Harry
starts an epic
[Music]
but the best part when Harry unleashes a
group of puppies to clean up the mess
does it get any better than Harry Styles
and some puppies I must say no but it is
only Wednesday
all right meanwhile Harry's ex Taylor
Swift has revealed the elusive tracklist
to her new album reputation now I'm
gonna ask you guys a question right away
what track names like king of my heart
this is why we can't have nice things
and New Year's Day what do you really
think of the names of these songs look I
respect the Swifty's I appreciate the
Taylor Swift stance so please don't come
free but don't Lee sound kind of corny
well they say never judge a book by it's
cover plus we do get a clap from Ed
Sheeran and future so that's exciting
but we'll have to just wait and listen
for ourselves except if you listen to
music on streaming services you may have
to wait to listen to hers Bloomberg is
reporting that Taylor Swift is
withholding the new album from streaming
services like Spotify and Apple music
for a week but you can still download it
on Apple music on November 10th and of
course go buy the physical CD but it
sounds like Taylor is leaning really
heavily on her fan to turn up and
actually buy this thing and you know
what I wouldn't bet against them I bet
they probably will in fact some fans
were even lucky enough to get an early
listen Taylor hand-picked 500 fans to
her secret sessions at her homes in
London Los Angeles Nashville and Rhode
Island over the past year and from the
looks of it the new music does not
disappoint
you my expectation that water every song
you just like this is my favorite and
then another one comes out this is my
favorite it was just everything I could
have asked for
a source at the LA session tells ET that
most of the songs on the new album are
not revenge songs and the party had huge
spreads of food and coop including cute
little red cookies no let us know you
guys how excited are you to hear this
album I know we are too I just may have
to wait a week
meanwhile the jury is still out whether
Taylor Swift will hit this year's Met
Gala but a trio of powerful ladies are
on tap to host this year's star-studded
affair Donatella Versace Amal Clooney
and Rihanna Donatella has attended 16
galas Amol made quite the splash at her
first one last year but it was only a
matter of time before Queen Rihanna took
the reigns of fashions biggest night she
has attended seven galas performed at
two and has consistently slayed that red
carpet sticking pretty close to the
theme in fact last year she nailed this
ray pal Kubo comme des Garcons look and
who can forget when she shut down the
carpet in 2015 in this Chinese couture
by boy pay all I'm saying is I cannot
wait to see what she turns out in this
year's theme which is heavenly bodies
fashion and the Catholic imagination I
could tell you a lot about that I was
raised Catholic are you guys that's it
for today from the Big Apple we are
flying back to LA tomorrow so in the
meantime ring that Bell so you don't
miss all the new episodes of The Daily
denne like and share this video and I
promise you I'll bring back some goodies
from the city I'm so excited